hi everyone my name is Jeremy van Hooser
today I'm really excited to reveal more
of the backyard battleground a brand new
feature for plants vs zombies garden
warfare 2 backyard battleground is a
massive living pvz world full of
surprises stories and secrets to
discover it is your personalized space
and home in the battle for zombie over
in the backyard battleground exciting
clashes between plants and zombies
happen constant and you're free to join
the battle or simply explore the grounds
and hunt for secrets and valuable
treasure when on the hunt for loot you
may even find something a little
unexpected like the new crazy targets
range crazy targets test your aim and a
frantic shooting gallery of fun your
best scores make it onto the leaderboard
where you can compete for the best times
against your friends or even the world
if you're itching for instant action
raise the flag of power right from the
center of the backyard battleground face
wave after wave of foes alone Oh with up
to three friends to rack up XP and coins
you can even switch sides and join the
zombie horde in their quest for total
fungi dominance in each faction space
you'll find all your multiplayer co-op
split screen and character customization
needs right in the middle of your base
you'll find a stat room this room
displays all your characters stats and
achievements there's also a sticker book
where you can get an overview of all the
characters and accessories you've
unlocked each of the classes have
bobbleheads that represents the
characters you have unlocked you will
also manage your character promotions
right here once you fully level the
character you'll be given the
opportunity to promote them promoting
grants your character a new title XP bar
and even a new vanquish screen to let
your hos know you mean business
outside you can head to the quest board
to take on challenges for coins and
stars which lead to sticker packs
upgrades and unlocks or you could run
over to the portals to embark on
missions for garden warfare 2's new
plant and zombie heroes like the Dave
bot 3000 and agent rose on your
adventure you will uncover secrets only
known to the most elite leaf agents or
top zombies in the field seriously top
secret stuff you guys we'd love to tell
you more but we don't want any spoilers
backyard battleground is one of the
largest pvz worlds we have ever created
and we're only just beginning to scratch
the surface in this video pick up all
around go on an adventure in solo play
train with your friends and much much
more welcome to your backyard
battleground
you